something that just chilled my blood was
when i spoke to one of the
um psychologists who sits on that
advisory panel
to ask if they'd been tasked with
thinking about how to get the british
population back to normal and he seemed
shocked
that i asked and if i could paraphrase
it's something like normal what normal
um you know we're now facing climate
change
and we've made great gains on carbon
emissions and we can't go back to normal
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kissing and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our brilliant guest today is the author
of this book a state of fear laura
dodsworth welcome to trigonometry hi
thank you for having me it's great to
have you on the show we're going to talk
about the book in a second but before we
do
just tell everybody a little bit about
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey of the lead
you to be sitting here talking to us
oh my goodness there's quite a lot in
there let's say oh
let's break it down i suppose the reason
i'm here right now is the book is
i suppose in essence it's quite a
reaction we've we've just been living
through
an absolutely extraordinary time in
british life and politics
and i didn't i didn't have a plan to
write a book like that
but i i just had to react to what was
going on around me
in the world and then before that i've
been a writer and a photographer for
some years i think of myself as a
creative and a storyteller
well it's it's a story that needs to be
told this book is about
how the government has used essentially
psychology to
to scare people uh into responding to
the pandemic and to the lockdown and to
the restrictions
in the way that they've wanted and i
wanted to open with a quote that you
you give from um the scientific pandemic
influenza group
on behavior which was in march of 2020
which is
they say the perceived level of personal
threat
needs to be increased among those who
are complacent
using hard-hitting emotional messaging
is that what this is all about in the
last year that
we've had a pandemic and the government
has sought to
shape our response to it through
hard-hitting emotional messaging is that
why we're seeing polling
results now that boggle the mind in
terms of the number of people who
support
curfews permanent restrictions permanent
wearing of mass i mean you can go down
the list
in terms of the stuff that people
believe people when polled believe that
i think like 10 percent of the public
have died from covet if
asked on the street so is that how we're
here
yes i'd say so so first of all to kind
of
add an annoying caveat i feel like i
have to say at the beginning which is
this book doesn't refute that covid is a
serious disease and people have died and
that we've been a pandemic
not at all but as one of the
psychologists
i interviewed said to me in the absence
of a vaccine
the the tool you have is psychology
that's their opinion they're a
psychologist they would say that
they also said to me that psychology has
had a very good epidemic
so the government decided to go the
route of imposing lockdowns
and very strict regulations to control
behavior to
limit transmission and to protect the
nhs i know that goal posts have moved
lots of times but if you remember the
original goal post it was flatten the
curve
to protect the nhs and
that minute from an extraordinary
document which was produced by spyby
that's the scientific
pandemic influenza group on behavior
which reports into sage and into the
government
is answering a question and the question
is how do we make people comply with
lockdown rules
so there's a whole host of options in
the document and one of them
sets out very clearly in black and white
that the british public
should be frightened into complying so
that is exhibit a
in the thesis that the government has
used fear to control behavior during the
epidemic
and i think we can still see it
happening now in
in lots of ways we could you know we
could talk about things that are going
on now like
nudges maybe to increase vaccination
uptake by constantly dangling the threat
of covered passes
and as a result for some people perhaps
their fear and anxiety is out of scale
with the severity of the threats that
we're currently experiencing
and that could be why people are
very supportive still restrictive
measures and
overestimate the um the threat of the
disease when they're asked in polls
but laura hang on a second so let's go
back to that first lockdown
we didn't know what was happening we
didn't know how virulent the virus was
we didn't know a lot about it wasn't the
first
lockdown and quite a tough advertising
campaign the way to deal with this virus
um there are quite a few things to
separate out there first of all you
could
accept the premise that a lockdown was a
sensible precaution
it doesn't necessarily mean that it
needed
advertising that would exaggerate the
threat of the disease
it was understood right from the
beginning that kovid is very age
stratified and it's also
a risk to people with particular
identifiable clinical conditions
so telling everybody they were equally
at risk wouldn't necessarily
be the only way to enforce a lockdown i
can see how some people think it would
um and i think when all this is done and
dusted it will be really important to
have a debate about
what sort of messaging is appropriate
but i can see how some people would say
in the teeth of the crisis any any means
justified the end
the ends just by the means wrong way
wrong way around do you know what i mean
but this the book also isn't about
whether lockdowns are a good idea but i
have to say it became difficult in the
course of writing a book to completely
extricate lockdowns
and fear messaging and to that end
there's an appendix and it's called
lockdowns don't work
so you'll see where i'm coming from with
that but actually lockdowns were never
used
before march 2020 they don't feature in
pandemic plans in fact they were
contraindicated
because they're not based on strong
evidence they're based on simulations
which
the world health organizations warned
against before and they're known to be
very harmful and they're not known to
necessarily
impact transmission i think you'll find
here that anybody that supported
lockdowns including the people who
enacted the policies
are going to try and tell us that
lockdowns are effective but there are
lots of empirical studies and
other countries around the world that i
think shake that
idea so you said that lockdowns are very
harmful let's just touch on that before
moving on
onwards because there's a lot of people
in this country i think the
the majority of the population are in
favor of lockdowns how a lockdown's
harmful
there's there's so much collateral
damage already from lockdowns and i
think it's still too early for people to
perceive all of the impacts
and i think it's it's fair to say that
the jury is still out
i never really thought it made sense
from day one
and i know that puts me in a real
outlier position
because i think telling people they
can't go out to work when they're
completely healthy
and not necessarily infectious is just
an extraordinary thing to do
to a family i mean that was me my work
just
stopped and i i was shocked i wouldn't
be able to go out and earn a living and
there would have been lots of people in
that position you know they were told to
put their relationships on hold
so it damages relationships not
everybody could work from home or
got the eventual furlough so stopped
income
i think probably most worryingly of all
we see in the nhs waiting list now how
many people were probably too frightened
to go to hospital i interviewed a
disaster and recovery planner who's
one of the foremost experts in this
country and in the world and she says
you just don't lock down
for a coronavirus she said in any
pandemic you know bluntly
you power through and she's involved in
planning mortuary
capacity and death planning and she said
that for every one
covert death they were planning another
four deaths as a result of lockdown and
associated risks over the
coming years so this isn't just let's
move on from lockdown because your book
really isn't about that it's really not
about life yeah
so let's move on from that i wouldn't
want anyone watching this to
uh watch this from a pro anti-lockdown
perspective i think
the important conversation is about the
methodology that's been used to
publicize and promote whatever has been
happening that's a much
more important conversation the locked
and prone anti-lockdown argument has
been had
including on our show many times true
but but you see you brought it up
because it is actually quite difficult
to execute because people say well
anything's justified if it kept people
in their homes if it made them follow
the lockdown rules
and that's why you can't completely
separate them right so let's just for
the sake of argument
say that lockdowns do work and in fact
they're extremely effective at stopping
a pandemic
and those of us like you and me who are
deeply concerned about the impact of
lockdowns
uh on health on cancer on heart disease
etc etc and mental well-being on
sides etc let's say that we're misguided
one of the arguments for example is that
all of that would have happened anyway
because if we didn't lock down the nhs
would have collapsed and you'd still
have
a massive backlog let's say for the sake
of argument all of that is true
is it not then ethical for the
government to use fear in the way that
they have
to get people to comply with rules that
they believe are necessary to protect
the public
i think it's a really thorny debate
in the course of researching the book
i've come to a very skeptical position
on that
but i accept there'd be different
opinions and i think that
actually that in the inevitable inquiry
it's going to be
really important to tackle the fear
messaging specifically
you know you've got to remember that the
advertising standards authority codifies
against this
for a reason um there were specific
campaigns which misled on the risk
and there was a government campaign that
had to be withdrawn um it was found
against by the advertising standards
authority
and there are others that just just
exaggerated the risks for the wrong
groups people there's one i remember
that was um
a group of teenage boys sitting in a
park and it said covered kills
well coveted hasn't really killed
teenage boys especially outdoors in a
park
so was was that the way to make them
stay indoors
and observe lot dam rules well if you
think that people won't behave
unless they're frightened maybe you'd
think that
but what about a more honest campaign
about who's at risk and what we all need
to do to protect those people
the argument would be it's not an
argument that i particularly support but
i want to put
the fully fledged counterpoint here
because i think that's the point of
having the conversation
would be well teenage boys are not being
killed by covet but
they're picking if they were to catch it
by socializing outdoors when covert is
rampant in in march and april of 2020
they go home spread it to their parents
their parents might be fine as well
their parents go and visit granny or
whatever because they they deliver some
shopping
and then we killed granny by that
so what what is the argument against
scaring teenagers into not going out
when
arguably those teenagers are potentially
spreading covet
to people who are vulnerable
i think that at the beginning um
probably government um politicians and
advisers acted
maybe in a panic and they didn't think
about the end result
what's the end result of a pandemic we
want everyone to be
healthy you know as many people as five
as possible and society to go back to
normal
if you want to get to that end point you
don't terrify people
we went into this without an exit
strategy so one of the problems
with the tactic of frightening people
who
are not in a risk category is that
everybody's fear
is amplified to a degree that we can't
get it back down
so a psychologist has identified a
syndrome now called covid anxiety
syndrome
whereby 20 of people are engaging in
overly obsessive hygiene or they don't
go outside
we know from ons figures that half of
the people who are clinically shielding
are still shielding even though they
don't need to be because they're
vaccinated
we know from polls there were some
really extraordinary figures i read
last week that i think it's i think 71
percent of people according
to yougov um want people to carry away
masks
on public transport um or this is an
even better one
it was reported in the ft that nineteen
percent of people want there to be a 10
pm curfew
beyond covid i don't know who these
people are
they walk among us who are they maybe
they don't maybe they're just
one of the problems with the fear
messaging is that it's hard for people
to get back to normal
fear makes recovery harder there's also
been an impact on some people's mental
health you know people have developed
ocds agrophobia
people developed depression there have
been various ons studies showing that
people developed depression
um in lockdown and it's difficult to
extricate how much will come from
fearful messaging how much will come
from lockdown how much we've come from a
natural fear of the epidemic
but there's a lot there's a lot going on
another problem
with that type of advertising
advertising is only one tool to frighten
people but it's a big one and it was
costly as well it's
a lot of monies a lot of our taxpayers
money's been spent on this
um another problem is it deflects
criticism so it doesn't just frighten
people puts people into groups
are you good are you a coveted hero or
are you a covidia and a granny killer
and it encourages ill will and blame and
finger-pointing between people
do you remember the ad campaign look him
in the eyes and tell him you never bend
the rules
so presumably matt hancock is somebody
who would have signed off on that so
first of all
let's just get that in it's a bit
hypocritical
well you might have seen something i
haven't seen i've just seen a little a
little bit of footage in the sun
my eyes um but it also
creates finger pointing among people so
instead of going well you know hang on
should we point the finger at policies
at politicians
at the big issues what about no
sarcomere infection people move from
care homes
from hospitals to care homes the ppe
scandal
we're pointing the the finger at rule
breakers
so instead of the kind of solidarity
that you want in people
in an epidemic we're divided into the
good guys and the bad guys and of course
what that does
creates kind of like herd mentality
um and othering and dehumanizing of
other people
also you talk about the young people is
that really fair to put that
responsibility
onto them and granny killer is one of
the most unedifying things
i've ever heard one of my sons was
shouted out in a corridor at school when
he wasn't wearing his mask correctly
and the teacher shouted you're killing
people
well you know if he was literally
killing people that would be a police
matter wasn't it
but his mask was a half-mast in a school
corridor
so what's the impact
on teenagers and children of being told
they can literally kill
their grandparents and the elderly it's
an enormous responsibility
and let's not forget at the beginning of
the epidemic it was acknowledged that a
lot of people that would die
were people who would die at some point
in the coming year or so anyway because
it was
the elderly were most at risk i think it
was professional ferguson who said that
in quite an early press briefing
so to put that blame on to young people
i just think is really
disproportionate and unfair we're not
the only country that did that
in germany what's now known as the panic
papers which are reported on in veltam
sontag
involved leaked emails between
politicians and scientists asking them
to basically
exaggerate the risks of the disease
and use fear messaging in order to
encourage compliance with the rules
quite similar
but they went into more lurid detail
than the the spy b minute that you quote
from my book
and one example that they give is that
children shouldn't be allowed to think
it's safe to go out and play outside
and you should play on the guilt so
they'll feel if they go and play outside
and then they infect people in their
household and their family dies
i just think that's a cruel thing to do
to a child and there's different ways of
doing it there's different ways of
communicating risk
does it have to be frightening do you
have a website or do you plan to have a
website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
it's an incredibly good point that you
make do not worry that
the government has used this tool and
has proved surprisingly effective
it's now in their toolkit forever they
can take this out
at whatever point they want again or do
you think it's a one-off thing
um nervous giggle i would love to think
it's a one-off thing but i don't really
see why it would be
um i've got i've got no reason to
believe that it is of course incredibly
effective
um i just wrote a feature for the
telegraph about the nudges we'll see
during the rest of the epidemic and i
checked in with one of my anonymous
sources who advises in government
who told me that there is skipping in
whitehall and
they're skipping through the corridors
they've had a very good epidemic
and one of the big learnings is that the
british people have been sheepish and
there's lots more nudge coming
it's worked why would they not do it
again um
if you've read the book guys if you've
read the book you might remember how the
chapter on spy b
starts and something that just chilled
my blood was when i spoke to one of the
um psychologists who sits on that
advisory panel
to ask if they'd been tasked with
thinking about how to get the british
population back to normal and he seemed
shocked
that i asked and if i could paraphrase
it's something like normal what normal
um you know we're now facing climate
change
and we've made great gains on carbon
emissions and we can't go back to normal
and i think you can already see um a
segway into using some of the same tools
to perhaps
encourage behavior change that will be
needed to meet net zero targets i've
seen a very scary ad produced by net
zero scotland already
well the something francis and i talked
about we did an episode where him and i
were talking about this and
uh the the fact that this is now part of
the toolbox
that can be produced for other perceived
threats
is something that people should be very
worried about i think
um but um in terms of the
the methodology tell everybody you use
you reference
nudge which we most of us understand but
some people may be less familiar with
what is nudge theory and how has it been
used in particular
for this pandemic but also previously
because i think it was cameron who
really first started talking about it
maybe it was
even used before tell everybody a little
bit about that yeah sure so
the nudge unit is the colloquial term
for the behavioral insights team which
was set up under the david cameron
government
and that's now um legally and
operationally separate to the government
it's a limited company
britain's terribly good at behavioural
psychology we actually or behavioral
science we export it all around the
world
they have offices in canada australia
new zealand and others um so a nudge is
implicit
which means you won't really be aware of
it it affects your choices without being
a mandate and nudge is just one tool in
the behavioral science
toolbox so there's the behavioral
insights team and
they've been doing some things that look
kind of innocuous in terms of making
people pay their tax returns on time or
um i don't know if they work on that but
that that might be the
that's the kind of thing five people
plastic bags yeah yeah exactly it's
choice architecture it's giving you a
choice and trying to nudge you into the
the right one the one that makes you a
model citizen the one that somewhere
some clever people in a clever room have
decided that you not so clever people
should be doing
um there isn't just the paper insights
team there's spy b
which we've already referred to now
that's a voluntary group
of advisors and they don't just work on
the covered epidemic they also advise
the government on other risks and other
things
on the national risk register but what
what i found fascinating but bit
disturbing in the course of researching
the books
book was how many brick walls i hit when
i was trying to find out more about
behavioral science and government but
what became clear to me is how much the
government does rely on behavioral
science
there are behavioral scientists in i
think probably every government
department
also within the nhs also within public
health england
there are also units which are set up to
manage the flow of information manage
counter disinformation
you might call some of it propaganda you
might call some of it behavioral
psychology
what they do is a little bit opaque
there's the counter disinformation unit
and there's the research
information communication unit there's
gchq
there's the 77th brigade which is part
of the army
and haven't you been surprised at how
easily manipulated it seems a british
public have been
i certainly have i found it shocking
i don't know i've gone through all kinds
of different emotions about it
the thing is epidemics are really
frightening um
i might not have thought lockdown was a
good idea but i was also frightened
about the epidemic at the beginning
i remember stocking up on tinned food in
case i got in my kids would have to
cook on their own you know um
it's it's normal it's hard baked into us
to be frightened i think fear was an
open door
and that's that's the point it was
really easy for the government to
leverage it because fear was
was already there and
behavioral science works i mean it's
advertising it's the bakery in the
supermarket it's all around us
all the time i don't know if the british
people have been especially sheepish
that's what the advisor's view was i
quoted them in this this telegraph
feature
i don't know because i haven't done
enough um comparison of attitudes
in different countries to be sure it
might just be that it was wielded a lot
more
heavily on us but surely when you have
access to facts because we all
we all have the internet doesn't that
mean that you're able to
challenge the government's propaganda
far more effectively and think for
yourself
well it depends what you rely on for for
your news sources
that's the thing um i was looking up
infection fatality rates at the
beginning
but a lot of people if they're relying
on the downing street press briefings
or just mainstream news stories which
are
more what's the word
fear-mongering at the beginning um not
everybody goes off and researches
alternate sources of information
to to get that balance not all media's
been equal in this time i think it's
been a bit of a mixed bag
one one of the experiences has really
struck me particularly over the last few
months as
covet has become far less dangerous
we've got the vaccine program which has
been a huge success
far fewer people are being infected far
fewer people are being
uh are in hospital far fewer people are
dying and
every time there's a conversation
whether it's on television or any or in
papers or whatever
when i am saying well look we've got
we've got
more people more hospitals in england
than people with coveton hospital this
is
at the time the government delayed the
freedom day last time that was the case
i'm saying look the average number of
deaths from covert with covet not from
covered it's like
in low 20s let's say so very few people
are dying from covet out of a daily
death toll of about 1400
or you know you are not a threat if you
are
under the age of 18. these obvious facts
that everybody including the scientist
will
accept and yet the response from the
public to that information if it's
reaching them at all
is just so disproportionate and and
that's where
you know we started to go well we need
to talk to laura about this because
i i feel like in the book you've got the
explanation of that
disconnect between the facts on the one
hand and the public
response on the other do you think that
the rational way that some people are
reacting to what's happening
is a product of that fear or do you
think it was always going to happen
because people just are irrational
anyway
oh i don't know i don't have the
in-depth answer to whether people are
irrational anyway
i mean i i've seen i've seen information
from people not being
generally very good at understanding
risks and numbers and i get that
and i think the first hit hurts the most
so the thing is you see the scary ads
i mean right at the beginning i remember
one which showed somebody on a gurney
but their head was just kind of
conveniently out of frame
these things were very subtle gives you
the impression that they don't have a
head
well of course you know you know they
have a head but it looks a bit scary and
and health workers with with big masks
on
and it looked like something out of a
horror film and
you know the like the language is very
dramatic you see that
that's what gets you not later on doing
a bit of research into
infection fatality rates i talked to a
broad sheet journalist
anonymously for the chapter in the media
and
you know they were explaining that
sometimes it's just a race to get the
news out you know you want to be first
so if you remember the um witty and
balanced
shock and awe presentation i call it the
shock and all presentation last autumn
and when they were talking do you
remember the the steep red scary lines
and afterwards they kind of had their
knuckles wrapped a little bit by
by theresa may and the national
statistics authority
um obviously newspapers reported on that
straight away
because the figures were shocking and
then later on you get the pieces that
go into more granular detail and say
well it's not really going to be as bad
as all that
but what hits people the most it's the
first story it's the steep red line it's
the big scary number
and what would you say to people who go
look we've always had a history of doing
this in a pandemic look at the aids
campaign in the
mid 80s don't die of ignorance with the
tombstone literally falling
and then making that huge sound what
what would you say to those people
um what are those people saying exactly
so i know what you're saying all right
so essentially you know that we've
always done this in pandemics look at
the hiv aids pandemic
the very famous advertisement with the
gravestone falling
and then joined the john hurts narration
with the words don't die of ignorance
well that is a good comparison because
it was
frightening there are quite a few
differences and quite a few similarities
um somebody interviewed for the book um
professor
knuckowski talked about that from when
he was in germany and he said he really
struggled at the time because
he knew this wasn't a virus that was
going to affect children but for
instance messaging at the time was
children shouldn't touch each other's
toys they'll catch aids
you know the risks were perhaps not very
well understood right at the beginning
and then exaggerated and
some of the early aids campaigning told
gay men not to have sex well that just
goes completely against human nature
don't be silly and then it moves to
safe sex and people go back and look at
that
that campaign and assume it was really
successful
but i think that it might be a bit
muddled up with people wanting
to say it was successful and ignoring
the impacts of grassroots
work at the time you know needle
exchanges and other things
you might be younger than me but i
remember that campaign
and i didn't really know what it was
about except that it was to do something
something very
very scary called sex and it was it just
really it had an impact on me but i
didn't really know why i was scared
i'm not sure that i needed that um
i don't think it's particularly
emotionally scarred or anything it's
fine
i guess the core of france's question
and this is something i wanted to ask
you about anyway is
is it not appropriate for the government
sometimes to exaggerate the threat
in order to get people to pay attention
to something
and to follow rules so for example in a
time of war
the government wouldn't be releasing the
day-to-day
information about what's happening
because there's a there's a reason for
that now in war it's obviously
so that the enemy doesn't find out
what's going on but there are there are
situations
in which it's okay for the government
not to be telling the full truth about
what's going on that's i guess the core
of the argument
uh what do you make of that in this
context i don't
know i i think it's a debate
i i not going to appoint myself benign
dictator of the world and think that i
know best
i think it really needs to be
scrutinized
with expert witnesses in a consultation
i don't like the lack of honesty and i
don't like the lack of transparency
i mean you're right in a in a war some
information would be withheld but in
fact we had the opposite we were flooded
with gloomy
numbers and we were the fallen you know
we've been subjected to
frightening metrics all the way through
but there's been a slight lack of
honesty
sometimes about what they mean and a
lack of context
which has created a disproportionate
level of fear which has brought its own
host of collateral damages like
an increase in alcohol abuse and
increase in opiate addictions and
increase some mental health problems
and people being too scared to go to the
hospital and then dying at home
people going too late for heart
conditions and now it's too late for
effective treatment i mean there's just
so much collateral damage
from frightening people
disproportionately i mean we were told
about deaths but never recoveries
why why give one figure but not the
other
the hospital admissions number has
always been quite one of the prominent
numbers on the
government covered dashboard but it
doesn't tell you what you think it does
you might think it means how many people
were admitted to hospital with covid
well
it includes those people it also
includes people who went to hospital
routinely for something else
and then they were diagnosed with covid
and it also includes people who caught
covid in hospital
that's more than you think so that's an
important number and when you're
planning how far apart
beds need to be spaced and staffing it's
a really important number
but it's not the number people thought
it was so there's
i think there's a whole chapter on the
metrics of fear in the book there's lots
of ways in which numbers were
presented in ways that inflated alarm
and amplified fear and it's so
interesting you say that because
what these numbers did is it unleashed
the petty authoritarianism across the
country
not only from newspapers but also people
being encouraged to snitch on their
neighbors
it felt like we were living out of
something from the soviet union
yeah don't talk about it well it has had
a bit of a whiff of community block
policing about it
i remember the first time i heard about
a snitch line i was really depressed
i thought no don't do this um it was
just
awful and even you know as we've been
coming into recovery
some of the messaging has been really
just depressing one minister said yeah
you know tell people that you'll report
them if you see them hugging
let's just tell matt hancock
it's just really depressing and that's
what i meant before about dividing
people
it's not just about creating fear it's
also about hating groups
and dehumanizing and snitching on
on the naughty ones i mean they've been
some very unedifying moments
do you remember two teenagers two
students were
they might not be teenagers but students
so find ten thousand pounds each for
organizing a snowball fight in january
good really what no i'm jolting i'm
miserable i've got back pain but no but
do you serious ten even though we knew
the science at the time
that was highly unlikely for people to
catch covet outside
even though we knew that and these fines
are literally the worst finds since the
time of
the sheriff nottingham i mean really
they're the worst finds you have to go
back to the dark ages
and that's what we've done to because
that makes you then terrified to break
the rules
and some people might say good you know
don't do the time don't do the crime
um but it's pretty steep fine for
students well and to add to that the
fact that the
i don't think there's been a single
prosecution under the rules that were
brought in that was that actually got
upheld in court they were all challenged
and all overturned so people are scared
not to break rules but when those rules
are actually tested those rules
are unenforceable by their very nature
in some in some instances
can i just jump in and say something
yeah is that right because you said
before we started i was allowed to jump
in so
yeah i've got something to jump in as
much
because i think you asking me well is it
okay to use fear it's good you should be
challenging me i don't mind a
challenging interview
and i would say i've got my own views
i'm quite opinionated
but it needs public consultation if
that's really important
but i just want to say that some of the
most damning indictments come from
psychologists
that i interviewed and government
advisors and
that's that's part of the spine of the
book to be honest
you know i spoke to one long-standing
government advisor who told me that
they're stunned by the weaponization
of behavioural psychology and i spoke to
a psychologist who
is on spy b who said that they wake up
at 3 a.m
with the fear of what they've done and
there's dystopia that's being created
so this isn't just some mad rambling
thesis of mine
i've interviewed a multitude of
professionals
and academics who not only share these
concerns they voice them more clearly
than me
and you say dystopia i mean that's a
pretty strong word to use what do you
mean by the title is it
look around my friend well look i mean
look people would say oh come on but
we're not living you know
you're not getting carted off we don't
have goo legs we don't have
concentration camps that's the true
meaning of a dystopian
you set a high standard there great as
long as we're not there we're fine okay
yeah i'll be the first in the
re-education gulag probably
embroidering face masks or something i
don't know
it's not me who called it a dystopia but
i think there's aspects of this year
that have felt dystopian
you know whatever i think there's been a
lot of fear in the in the air and you
caught it one way or the other
and whatever dystopia means to you
it's probably felt dystopian one way or
another to a lot of people
it has felt dystopian to me the the
moment where i
started to lose faith in the government
was the issue of masks
where at the start they said oh no you
shouldn't wear masks there's no
evidence you know the evidence is weak
surrounding masks
and isn't the evidence weak surrounding
mask anyway
but it seems that we've now been turned
against each other
yeah this is this is a kind of a classic
example
of of where the thesis of my book takes
you
but it's still so controversial to talk
about because people are largely in
favor
and they're largely in favor because
they've been told by their government
that their mask protects other people
the government's own website not the
kind of like the basic
advice bit go into their policy papers
says that the evidence is weak and it's
limited there isn't good hard evidence
in favor of masks
flyweight would be fair there's one
randomized controlled trial into mask
use
the dan mask study i interviewed one of
the authors for the book
and to be fair that that study was about
whether your master protects you
that's what they chose to investigate
the time and they say it may be that the
study is statistically underpowered but
they can't find a statistical
significant improvement from wearing a
mask
so that's the best study that we've got
now about wearing masks in the community
it's very mixed and and i spoke to an mp
who told me anonymously that mosques
were
brought in he hasn't good authority they
were brought in
um because the economic bounce back
wasn't good enough after the
first lot down and then the behavioral
scientists realize that they are a good
signal because
when you see people in masks you're
reminded that there's an epidemic it's
dangerous out there we become walking
billboards for danger and epidemic a
virus and fear
so it might encourage people to follow
the rules
they also represent solidarity
apparently according to some of the spy
bee advisors they love words like
solidarity and collectivism they love
the idea that we're all in it together
in our masks
so sounds very familiar
yeah so um the evidence isn't good but
people now firmly believe
it is because that's what they've been
told and i i just think it's a
really shocking thing to have done to a
population it is and i've i've seen it
it happened because uh you talk about
mars i was just talking to
a friend of a friend uh who i remember
at the
beginning of pandemic she's a vet and
she was saying we don't need to wear
masks
i wear a mask while i'm doing surgery on
an animal to prevent my saliva from
going into the wound
but apart from that just wash your hands
don't you know
hug strangers whatever for the moment
but you don't need to wear a mask
fast forward eight months later this
person is saying they will never stop
wearing a mask for the rest of their
life
and that has happened to someone who's a
medical professional
in the space of eight months so how how
that
has affected people who don't even have
that medical knowledge
i i only dare to think really
oh yeah i think we're not careful
they're going to stay around and did you
see
some of the williams sisters i can't
remember which one maybe because i
couldn't see her face
but she's wearing this dress that has
this cowl neck that doubles up as a mask
and it's got a lot of people
serena serena okay and i saw that i was
like oh no please god
no don't incorporate it into dresses i'm
not buying one of those
but also do you do you know do we really
think that virus labs around the world
are going to adopt that
as their as their ppe no
but laura the question i wanted to ask
you is is about
what's happening now because we're now
at a point where
we're approaching the lifting of
restrictions here in the uk
uh the despite the fact that basically
most of the public don't seem to want it
to happen
and we seem to be in a position now
where the government you alluded to
earlier they believe that they are
entitled
to threaten people with taking away
their rights which up until this point
in human civilization have always been
considered
absolute and unrestrictable by
government which is your right to
meet people your right of association
your right to be outdoors etc
they they are now saying that if you're
not vaccinated
you will not be able to enjoy those
rights like
going into a pub or whatever even though
i don't think they believe that
the restrictions themselves are
necessary so in other words
they're scaring people with taking away
rights that don't need to be taken away
just to force young people in this
instance to take the vaccine
i mean why is no one saying that that's
unethical
other than like three of us well i think
there are more than that it's quite a
difficult
conversation to have and i think that
some of the media are running scared
because it's difficult to talk about it
without standing critical of the vaccine
program or critical of the vaccine and
god forbid you'd want to be on the
anti-vaxx team and i'm going to do
another caveat here
i'm not an anti-vaxxer i've had
childhood vaccinations travel
vaccinations blah blah blah
but laura just to interrupt you there
isn't that the problem
can you not be critical of this vaccine
and say look i'm worried about it a lot
of it uses new technology
i'm not sure if i want to be exposed to
this new technology
automatically boom anti-vaxxer those are
two
completely different positions surely
well they should be
they should be but they've but they're
not at the moment and the time refuse
nick was used it kind of floated up all
at once and then it went away because
people said it wasn't appropriate
a positive term if someone refuses to
comply with government dictator but
anyway let's not get but it wasn't used
like that here was it
so there's a lot of nudging going on i
and i
i agree with you i think that the threat
of the covid pass is to encourage young
people to have the vaccine
now do we believe that parliament can do
a good job when allowed to follow
parliamentary process
i believe it i love this country i love
democracy i love politics
there was a select committee into the
use of covered passes
and it found against them so there's no
scientific justification
so that's that's the result of a select
committee into the cover pass
um and yet they're being threatened
and i think it is to encourage the young
to get vaccinated right
but informed consent shouldn't work that
way it shouldn't be based on a threat
or creating a two-tier checkpoint
society
your choice to have any medical
intervention including a vaccine
should be simple benefit harm calculus
and if you're not sure it's right for
you the best thing for you to do is to
talk to your doctor
i think if you're not sure then
threatening somebody that they won't be
able to go to a football stadium or a
bar
isn't the right way to reassure them
it's it's a threat
the other thing that's happening at the
moment is incentives and this is
completely new to this country so
the mayor of london's office was giving
away tickets to watch
the final in trafalgar square and also
one pair of tickets to watch it live
and charlton athletic gave away a
thousand tickets
um to the first thousand to be
vaccinated in the stadium
and i wanted to write about this in this
piece i just wrote about nudges
and neither charlton nor the mayor's
office would come back to me on the
issue
of whether an incentive affects informed
consent
but of course it does that's the point
of that that's the point and i spoke to
a public health specialist who's a very
keen
vaccine advocate who said she's very
concerned about the impact
on informed consent we've never done
this before i think we have to be really
really careful that in racing racing to
get to the finish line the happy ending
of this
horrible story of a pandemic we don't
cross rubicons and i think we are
crossing
rubicons at the moment now if you're
somebody who's resistant to the idea of
a vaccine i really don't see
how the incentive or the threat will
really make you have it what you need is
to look at the risk and the harm
for your your personal circumstances
and and talk to a doctor
hey francis think about all the times
you've used wi-fi at a coffee shop a
hotel
or even at your parents house happy
memories
well without expressvpn every site you
visit could be locked by the admin of
that network
and that's still true even when you're
in cognitive mode even when you're in
cognitive mode still happy memories what
what's more
your home internet provider i'm talking
comcast at t
whatever can also see and record your
browsing data
and they're legally allowed to sell it
on to others
i'm so screwed you are
trigonometry is now going to be a solo
project
and that is why i use expressvpn
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data
and re-routes it through a network of
secure servers
so that your private online activity
stays just that
private
unfortunately so sadly every site you
visit
every video you watch or message you
send gets tracked and data mined
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
so expressvpn makes your activity harder
to trace
and sell to advertisers finish
absolutely
done for and the best part is how easy
it is to use
the app literally has one button you tap
it to connect and your browsing
activities secure from your parents eyes
for answers
please stop crying my new suede shoes
are getting wet
if you don't want to end up like me and
stop your parents from protecting your
privacy
go to expressvpn.com
trigger and get three extra months for
free
that's e x p r e
s s v p n dot com
trigger go to expressvpn.com
trigger to learn more
and laura doesn't it also show a
complete contempt for ordinary working
people because we saw in america as well
they were giving out lotto tickets you
could get a burger and fries
do they really when you got excited yeah
it was actually that's when i thought
right i'm jumping on a plane to america
but in all seriousness doesn't that show
a complete contempt
of ordinary people that they can be so
easily manipulated
borrow from tickets to watch charlton
athletic who let's be fair are [ __ ] and
yes there are probably three charlton
fans watching this and you are
um i think that's the diplomatic um with
which laura started her i
because you know that my my football
watching is just like
england in the euros i don't watch
specific teams i'm so sorry charlton i
bet
i bet they're great though you know no
they're really not they're not
well i mean the incentives in the u.s
are much worse than that i mean they're
really the wild
west of incentives oh my god so i wrote
about this for spectator world their us
edition
they've had jabs for joints i mean
seriously
take a vaccine and have drugs that here
would be illegal um
this one's quite funny lap dances for a
year if you get vaccinated
what i know now he's excited i thought
it was the burgess that was gonna do
krispy kreme doughnuts every day if you
get vaccinated
and i find i find that one actually
really incongruous because
one of the um really key comorbidities
with covid that no one's talking about
is obesity
so the idea of eating a doughnut every
day to you're not going to eat your way
into optimum health that way are you
um free beer i think it was budweiser
said if 70
of the u.s population got vaccinated by
fourth of july they'd do a free beer for
everyone
i don't know if they hit that target
they've but they've been doing some
really significant
cash lotteries as well free flights and
raffles and i think most you know worst
of all
college education raffles as well
because that's a big incentive
so if you're 18 uh or 17 when they apply
for college
um the risk calculus for the benefit you
know the benefit of the vaccine is is
looking
i i'm not going to comment god science
people get really angry with me
i think you're on shaky ground to um
convince me that a 17 year old
needs the vaccine like this let's phrase
it like this if you're in your 80s and
you've got co-morbidities
the risk reward is very different to if
you're in your 20s and you've got no
comorbidity let's just phrase it like
that and i'm talking about 17 and 18
years
old but the idea of a free college
education is a massive draw that is a
big carrot
right so the the fact you know we don't
want to be like the united states do we
also they actually don't have very high
um uptake to vaccinations
for a lot of their programs and the
british are um you know we have a very
high uptake we don't have covert passes
because most people just
duly go and get vaccinated i mean this
array
of incentives may end up and threats may
end up backfiring it may make people
feel more resistant because people don't
really like
being told what to do a vaccine really
interferes with your idea of personhood
and state yeah and it does
do you not and we've been skirting
around this issue as we've talked over
numerous topics is what we're seeing a
glorified form of divide and conquer
i think there's been lots of divide and
conquer um we've seen small ways from
snitch lines being told to report on
your neighbours for having a party
or going out more than once a day in the
lockdown
you know really nasty stuff just at a
time when people should be pulling
together and supporting each other in an
epidemic
to um oh what i saw today
um the vulnerable being told not to mix
with the unvaccinated
which i found quite depressing it's very
othering so
somebody might be unvaccinated but they
might have covid and have immunity from
that and somebody can be vaccinated and
still transmit covid
it's not it's not completely clear-cut
and binary
so i feel like that's another it's
another tactic it's another nudge
to say the vaccinated are clean and safe
and the unvaccinated are the
unclean and the unsafe and i think we
have to be really careful
about language that dehumanizes a whole
group of people
who might be unable or choosing not to
have a vaccine now
i won't say why but i can't have the
vaccine i'm medically exempt i'm one of
those people
that others are being told not to mix
with or that i might not be able to go
into bars and restaurants
and it's it's amazing you know that you
say that because
the whole point of our governmental
system is that you have an opposition
the opposition is meant to challenge
they're meant to push back on the
government if anything this law i'm all
for authoritarian yeah they're pushing
back on the government and they want
them to be more you know
do more of what they're doing yeah the
oppositional comes from within the
framework it's
it's not don't do that it's do more of
it do it harder do it longer do it
earlier
just do more um it's not pull a
different lever it's pull that lever
harder
and so it's not really an opposition
it's not
the opposition's coming from within the
conservative party yes from the cove
recovery group mps yeah yeah it is uh
and
i was obviously joking earlier i'm
disappointed with how labor have handled
this of course i am
uh really i didn't you expect it
uh no i didn't know how they'd react but
anyway look let's move on a little bit
um let me ask the tinfoil hat question
which uh our producer and i were sitting
here the
the other day talking about this like at
the beginning of the pandemic
when people started banging on about
various conspiracy theories
i was like zero chance not even
entertaining this
and as it's progressed it's gone from
like zero percent to 0.1 percent to like
one percent now are you growing
exponentially is your conspiracy theory
yeah i think i've got an internal
pandemic of the mind going on but
um why why is all of this happening
um i really don't know i really don't
know i remain very open-minded and
that's something about me i'm a really
really open-minded person and my book is
not why
it's how because i don't think we know
the why at the moment
it could just be that and i'm going to
go back to what the book is about how
the uk government weaponized fear during
the pandemic
it could simply be they wanted people to
follow the rules and they knew the rules
they were imposing were
a huge form of potentially necessary or
unnecessary
social engineering um it could be
that they panicked about the virus
themselves you know the teeth the crisis
and they panic so they threw away
all the old pandemic plans and did
something brand new copying china
um it can also be that there could be
vested interests at play i mean maybe it
serves
some people's interests you know we
there's been some scrutiny about
contracts that haven't gone through the
correct tendering process
you know you could have a coalescence
here of [ __ ] up
and um the road to hell being paved with
the
good intentions and conspiracy theory
terrain i don't really know i don't
really know
but um we just have to watch and see
you know someone gave me a good analogy
while the house is on fire you don't
know what started it you have to wait
for the ashes to cool
and our fire's still pretty hot at the
moment so we don't know
do you think we're ever going to get
back to normal as in the old normal as
in
where we used to be in 2019 why don't we
just normalize calling it normal yeah
well but this is g isn't this another
example of just the way
that we've been collectively brainwashed
the fact i'm referring to normality as
the old normal well it's really
interesting that i mean
i'm quite interested in the term the new
normal i'd quite like to do
i'd like somebody to pay me to do a
really good study into this actually
about how it spread
how did it spread was it a form of
linguistic contagion was there some
pandemic plan that was secretly passed
around governments
why did they all start saying new normal
so early
i put the date in my book i can't
remember the top of my head but dominic
rob used the term the new normal within
a few weeks of the first lockdown
now i'm very alert to language and at
the time i thought well why would you
say that
this sounds horrific what do you mean
what new normal i want to go back to
real normal
and i didn't understand then and i still
don't why you'd use a term
that implies that a whole way of being
has passed
you don't use the new normal unless it's
to signify some
new epoch so i don't know what that
means that would be an interesting thing
to explore i'm open-minded
but i don't want old normal back
actually i don't i
i know i shot you i don't because i
don't think it was good enough it wasn't
robust enough
um something that i've sort of grieved
over a little bit
is not the freedoms that were taken away
it's the fact that i really didn't have
freedom if it could be taken away so
easily
um and i think that we should be looking
at a sort of a bigger picture about how
how we make people
cherish freedom and democracy and
parliamentary process
and we need much much better more robust
systems in place for future pandemics or
crises
i don't think old normal was quite doing
the job if it's
gone so easily and it's still not back i
think we need something better
i i quite agree with you because when
they can abolish
and or outlaw protest and there doesn't
seem to be a murmur about it and then
you had the women's march and then you
saw those awful footage
of police officers kneeling on women's
back that was
that was the only time it seemed that
people started to wake up
as to what was happening and it was it
wasn't a lockdown protest
so it garnered a different level of
sympathy because the nature of it
and that's good it's i mean it's not
good that it happened it's horrific
but it's good that at least people
started talking about the right to
protest
there are a lot of really essential
basic human rights that were
um withheld from people and you could
argue that was necessary during a
pandemic or not
but it's it's how fragile our
relationship to those rights appears so
worship education protests even
elections you know the local elections
were cancelled
which yeah more shocking i thought
it was it was and what do you are you
optimistic about the future where is
this all going because
the concern you've just articulated is
my biggest concern about all of this
uh we've opened
not one and not two and not five and not
even ten
different pandora's boxes every every
aspect of the relationship between
the citizen and our representatives
has been completely and dramatically
changed in a very short period of time
without any democratic scrutiny
whatsoever
and so the question for me we started
with this but the question for me going
forward is are you optimistic
that we're not just going to live in a
completely different era now in which
everything we used to believe about
representative democracy
about government about our rights and
freedoms
it's just not going to be the same
anymore you're optimistic that we'll
make it
through this to a better normal i don't
know
i oscillate and i don't pretend to have
a crystal ball
for me july 19th isn't freedom day i've
got no expectation of freedom
on july 19th i still i think we'll see a
return of some privileges
you know the privilege to go to a
restaurant or to a bar or to gather at
someone else's house in greater numbers
than
whatever it is i actually can't keep the
rules in my head anymore because they've
changed so much i
i get i get lost on the numbers but i
think we'll see the return of some
uh privileges because they're not
freedom if you have to buy them
negotiate plead exchange
um it's a stepping stone to just move
towards
a better version of freedom the thing
that i think we need is public
consultation on the use of behavioral
science because it's behavioural science
that made people so frightened it made
them comply with the rules
and it accounts for where we are right
now where people are re you know the
anxiety about the 19th and some
restrictions being lifted is
is palpable and that is not
proportionate
to the deaths or to the hospitalizations
i mean cases are a function of the
amount of testing and
shouldn't be the measure but but they
are it's a big number isn't it the big
numbers are the scary ones
so what i think we need as well as the
inevitable covert inquiry as a public
consultation and inquiry into the
government's reliance on behavioral
science
there have been various calls in the
past for consultation and they haven't
happened
and perhaps nobody thought it mattered
while they were just
you know quietly making cigarette
packaging plain or
encouraging us to pay our tax returns on
time or making us look at the biscuit
tin
but this time we were locked up and so
it matters i think it's time to
to look at what they're doing i think it
is time to look at what they're doing do
you think it was quite sinister
that boris johnson in that particular
press conference talked about personal
responsibility
almost as a way that if things do go
wrong the fault is not on the government
it's on the
is on the individual the general public
um i liked
him talking about personal
responsibility i think that the british
public should have been trusted all
along
you know the alternative to scaring
people with less to encourage
a lockdown would be to say well there
are certain things you know like really
big gatherings stadia you know
we need to apply some sensible measures
but there's this really dangerous
disease
it's particularly dangerous to these
categories of people and we would like
to ask you
to be mindful of this this and this
would we not have done it
i would have done i think most people
would have been
should have been trusted with uh honesty
and with personal responsibility
what um i thought was quite something in
that speech was he said we're changing
the tools
um to control human behavior that's the
bit that woke me up
tools to control human behavior it's
just out there in the open they just
talk about it quite
quite openly now and what do you think
he means by that um well he specifically
said away from legal restrictions and
towards personal responsibility which is
going in the right direction
but it's it's an honest labeling of
tools to control human behavior what are
all the tools i mean that they're in my
book
let's talk about them let's get some
expert witnesses talking about them
let's gather better evidence
let's find out who is behind these tools
how much does it cost us the taxpayer
what are we spending on behavioral
science in each government department
and our marketing campaigns why is it
not in manifestos
and what's the collateral damage which
you've talked about there's another
bit of this before we wrap up that i
find very interesting
you've alluded to it and it's a
conversation that's uh
certainly unhavable on television or in
in the newspapers but
the reality of this virus this this has
been acknowledged
obviously is particularly deadly to the
elderly but in terms of things that you
yourself can control
the one well not the one but a couple of
things we know
is obesity and your overall immune
system are two things that can provide
either very very bad outcomes or very
good outcomes depending on whether those
are things that are under control
and i we have seen a tremendous amount
of messaging
of the negative type we i don't think
i've ever seen
an ad from the government about what i
can do
to protect myself from covid other than
stay at home no one has told me to
exercise no one's told me to eat better
no one's told me
to take vitamins no one has told me to
get fresh air no one's told me to get
the sun
no one's said any of these things yet we
know that of the things that you can
control
which is probably what all of us want to
know about
those are the things that you actually
can do to improve your
survivability to improve your likelihood
of transmission blah blah blah blah blah
so in terms of the you've done many
interviews for the book
was that ever discussed and and what are
your thoughts on why that's never
happened
i don't know it's baffling um it is
baffling and
it's it's something that's grated on me
since the beginning of the epidemic
so there's been discussion about whether
vitamin d helps not but we know it helps
with other respiratory diseases
obviously good nutrition exercise sleep
um and it's been known since very early
that obesity
appears to be a comorbidity diabetes
hypertensive disorder so there's a lot
of things that people could do
to improve their overall health and we
could have been working on that before
this winter
so i don't really i i don't know why
that hasn't been the focus um but it's
worse than that of course because fear
and stress
have psychopathological outcomes you
know affects the immune system and it
can
affect overall physical health so
frightening people could have also made
people sicker literally physically
sicker
not just affect mental health it's very
true
laura we could talk about this for a
very long time and probably just get
more and more depressed as we do
uh but listen we're going to ask you
some questions for our locals but before
we do we've got one final question for
you
which is always what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be
well we're going on holiday this summer
i'm kidding
um no that's what we should be talking
about shouldn't we
hmm we really should that's a good point
well francis and i have both been on
holiday already have you
yeah where did you go i went to ibiza
nice wow you swung that nicely in time
oh some little window of restrictions
and did you really
yeah i did the moment it it looks as if
it was going to open i said to the
girlfriend i went right
the moment the door opens we're going
for it because i don't know when it's
going to shut again
we both need a holiday and we just went
the moment open
we went nice good there's a good little
bit of information for you that's what
you tuned in
anyway laura thank you so much for
coming on the book is called a state of
fear i recommend people get it and check
it out for themselves
uh where else can people find your work
online um
my website is lauradsworth.com i'm a
writer and photographer and on twitter
and instagram i'm
at bear reality not bear the grizzly
bear
bare naked bear fantastic thank you so
much for coming on the show
thank you all for watching we're going
to do our locals questions in a second
but take care we'll see you very soon
with another fabulous effort episode or
a live stream all of them go out 7pm uk
time
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below